very happy about this recently the Ghana
ambassador to the United States ad Jay
Baer Weah that's him right there sent me
a letter
officially inviting me to visit the
Republic of Ghana and of course I said
yes
yeah all you have to do is ask me
recently very busy on has become a real
thriving regional power in West Africa
and I'm excited to explore its culture
and meet the Ghanaian people
I'm also joining a long line of
prominent Americans who have visited
Ghana Malcolm X visited Ghana Maya
Angelou Muhammad Ali Martin Luther King
jr. and add all that up and you get
Conan O'Brien yeah yeah it's gonna be
our next Conan Without Borders show if
you're watching those Conan in Ghana
and I like to have a friend so to help
to help me on my trip I'm bringing a pal
who's half Ghanaian one of the stars of
HBO's hit show veep very funny gentleman
Sam Richardson is coming with me
a huge fan of yours as you know and I'm
so excited you're coming with me and I'm
also hoping that maybe you can serve as
our translator Oh Conan the official
language of gun is called British
English didn't know that yeah this trip
is already a nightmare okay Sam and I
are gonna be leaving for Ghana next
Monday and I'll be documenting our
entire journey in real time on Team
Coco's Instagram Facebook and Twitter
accounts so make sure to follow us all
next week Sam thank you so much for
coming with me Sam
[Applause]